[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
recounting to us the Story of the birth
of Miam.
Miam, daughter of Imran, the mother of
Isaam.
And that is that her mother made fervent
dua to Allah subhanahu waala
that he blessed her
by accepting her offering of her child.
You see when
the wife of
the mother of Miam
the grandmother of Isa
when she found out she was pregnant she
made fervent dua
to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that he
accept
her offering of her child
who at the time was still in her womb
that oh Allah accept from me this
offering.
I hereby devote and dedicate
my child that is in my womb to your
service.
This child
is for your religion specifically.
And she made that vow
and she took the most precious thing to
her
which was her own flesh and blood her
child
and she endowed that child and dedicated
that child to Allah. But here's the
twist.
She thought that the child in her
stomach was a male. She thought it was a
boy.
And so she made this vow to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala thinking that this
was a boy he would be born and she would
send him to the
Kisa
to the house of worship and that this
boy would grow up amongst the prophets
amongst the scholars
of Benny Israel. in and be completely
devoted to serving the kinesisa.
And this was something that is largely
specific to boys as it is with our mass
that a boy is eligible to become the
imam, a boy is eligible to become the
muadin, etc. She thought this was a boy.
And so the surprise came when she had
her child and it was a girl.
She did not expect this.
She did not expect this and she did not
expect that Allah had very much so
accepted her vow and specifically
gave her a girl.
See in her mind this child was going to
serve Allah in a very specific way.
However, Allah subhanahua
he knows best.
He knows best what is needed when and
where.
AND SO, SURE, if she had had a boy, that
boy may have been a very great and
righteous man, but he would never have
been Miam.
He would never have been the mother of
Isa.
He would never have been one of three or
four women in the history of humanity
marked as the most righteous women in
all of history. cream of the crop,
Maria Maret.
And so when she had this child, it was a
girl and it was a very different scene
now in her than what was in her mind and
her plans.
But she knew that I have already made
this vow that this child is to the Kisa
and is to be dedicated to the houses of
worship. And so Zechariah,
he took her into his care and he was the
current prophet of Benel at the time,
the father of Yah.
And he
built for her a
he built for her a place of worship
specific to her
on the premises of the current
house of worship at the time at the
Kisa. And he made it to where she was in
a place where she could devote herself
to the worship of Allah. And she grew up
in the care and under the guidance of
Zachariah.
And Zachariah became a very old man at
the ripe old age of
120 years old.
Zechariah
went to see Modiam to bring her her
dinner and found that not once, not
twice, but constantly he would go to her
in the summertime to bring her her
dinner, her food, and find that she had
fruits that are only around during the
winter
that she's eating from. And during the
winter months, she would come and find
that she is enjoying fruits that are
only available during the summertime.
NOWHERE
IN ANY KNOWN PLACE COULD YOU FIND THAT
fruit at that time of year.
She he asked Miam, "Where are you
getting this from?" And she said,
And so she said, he said, "WHERE ARE YOU
getting these from?" She said, "This is
sustenance that has been sent to me from
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Allah indeed
does bestow upon whom he chooses, what
he chooses, and when." And at that
moment, Zechariah, even though he was
120 years old and his wife was over 80,
some say around 90, between 80 and 90
years old, he makes dua that Allah bless
him with a son.
And Allah gives him a son.
He gives him a son at 120 years old. A
person may look at this and say, "WHY
NOW? WHY NOT WHEN I WAS A young man? We
wouldn't have needed the miracle."
No, that's not the plan of Allah. Your
job, my job, what we are to learn from
these stories
is that you are to make yourself fit and
ready to be called upon by Allah.
And you are NOT TO DETERMINE for
yourself
how, when, or where you will be called
upon. You're just to make yourself
ready. IF YOU TRULY VOW YOURSELF FOR
ALLAH,
you will be ready AT ALL AND EVERY time
and moment,
preparing yourself to be called upon by
Allah. How? You don't know. And that's
not your job to know.
If Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala chooses to
use you, which is the the greatest
honor any of us could ever hope for, our
prophet sallall.aii Wasam tells us in
the narration of Annis. He says,
"WHOMEVER ALLAH CHOOSES AND DESIRES GOOD
FOR, he will use him before his death,
Allah will use him as a tool to further
his agenda." Subhanahu wa ta'ala and his
plan and his destiny and his that's the
greatest honor and any of us could hope
for but it is not our position to
dictate how when and where this this use
will take place we are merely tools
vessels
and the greatest of hearts are those
hearts which have been chosen by Allah
to bear his book his revelation the best
of hands hands are those hands which
have been chosen by Allah to further
his revelation. The best of feet are
those feet which have been chosen by
Allah. Those eyes which have been chosen
by Allah. Those ears which have been
chosen by Allah. those tongues WHICH
HAVE BEEN CHOSEN by Allah to be used for
the furtherance of his way and his
revelation.
And so many times we will find that
things don't work out the way that we
expected. And that is a good thing
because our expectations
in comparison to Allah's destiny, our
expectations are incredibly juvenile,
incredibly shortsighted.
A great man,
a great companion of our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam, he made a
statement regarding this issue. and
lines of poetry.
He said,
[Silence]
A great companion of our prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam said and it
does not matter to me
which side I fall on when I am martyed
for the sake of Allah
because my martyrdom is only for Allah
and if Allah so desires
he will place his baraka even in a torn
up twisted body.
This are the words of a man named
is one of the reciters of the Quran, one
of the memorizers of the Quran.
is a great hero of Islam
who said these words just before his
execution.
See what happened is
after the battle of
the mushik of and the neighboring
villages and the neighboring tribes
they were very very angry and they
wanted blood from the prophet
sallallah.aii
Wasam and his companions. But they
couldn't attack Medina. Every time they
met them in battle, they lose.
And so they resorted
to trickery
to try to get out as many companions as
they could out into the open into a
vulnerable place in order to kill them,
to ransom them, to take them as
prisoners, to take them as slaves. And
so it was
a man named Safwanbaya,
his father,
a great disbeliever
who was killed by the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam himself in the
battle of
he was so upset about his father's death
that he made an agreement with one of
his childhood friends.
He agreed with him. Look, I will take
care of your debts and your family.
Go pretend to be Muslim and go and
assassinate Muhammad. This was their
agreement.
And so Omeared himself and
childhood friends, what could go wrong?
And so he went to Medina and he became
Muslim IN SPITE OF HIMSELF. He went to
kill him. When he arrived there, he
found himself overwhelmed by the words
of Allah and he accepted Islam became
one of the best Muslim men. So every
attempt they MADE TO GET BACK at him
would fail. Every assassin
met them in legitimate Bided
you know
and let us say that we have become
Muslim
and draw out some of his companions. So
they DID THAT. THESE TWO tribes they
went to Medina. They sat with the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam and
they said we are starting to come around
to Islam. We're starting to warm up to
it and we're becoming Muslim quickly and
so we would for you to send with us
a delegation of your best companions
so that they can teach us the Quran and
teach us about the religion of Allah and
our tribe. And so the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
in the fourth year after hijah in the
month of Safar he sent a delegation of
10 companions
some of the best companions
was their commander their leader
and he sent with them
and he sent with them Zina
etc.
And so when they reached the outskirts
of Mecca around the tribes of Houd in a
place called Al
they called the those two tribes. They
came out and they chased the companions
up onto a mountain. 10 companions
against over 100 skilled archers.
They were referred to as the most
skilled archers in all of the Arab
Peninsula, that tribe. They were known
for their archery.
And so many of the companions decided
not to come down. And they fought until
they were martyed.
And there were only
four of them left.
And
he said to them, "We have to continue
fighting until death. If they take us as
prisoners,
you know that they will betray their
word." Because as they have them up on
this mound, they're saying, "Hey, JUST
COME DOWN. WE PROMISE we won't kill you.
We promise."
And so Aam said obviously I'm not going
to accept their word and they continued
to fight. They killed Asam. Three of
them now were left.
They came down. They said we have your
word. We give you our word. So when they
came down,
they said, "Come, come." And they took
out the
the part of their bow that the strings
from their bows and they started to tie
them up.
The other companion said
and so he started to fight and they
killed him as well. We are left with
and Zade. They tied them up, but they
didn't have any particular problem with
Hub and Zade. So what did they do? They
took our brothers Zade and Kub to the
slave market in Mecca
and they sold them to as slaves to the
tribe of
the son
of
who later become became Muslim. He
bought
and
another son, the son of Safwanbaya,
he bought Zate.
And so they kept them as prisoners for a
time and then took them out of the
borders of Mecca because they're very
righteous people. You see these
idoltors, they felt we cannot spill
their blood in the haram. This is a
sacred place. Let us go murder them
outside of the haram. So they took them
to a tenim to kill them.
And they did so.
But during that time,
Zade and
remember they were sent to call to
Allah. They came out of Medina were sent
by the prophet sallall.aii
as a delegation of teachers. They came
out to teach.
They had in their minds a very specific
way this was going to play out. They
were going to have students and teach
the book of Allah etc.
Very as we all have plans in our lives.
But their da was to be very different
than their expectation.
They were taken out to aim.
And as they were kept as prisoners,
the daughter
of
Alh hadith, she said about Kub, "We kept
him as a prisoner in our home.
And every time I would come to him, I
would see him eating fruits that are not
found in Mecca during that time."
impossible to find those fruits in the
Arab peninsula at that time.
He is chained
and held prisoner and somehow he has the
best of fruits there from Allah
subhanahu wa tala. And so when they told
him, "We are going to execute you now."
He asked for a razor so that he could
prepare his body.
He could shave himself and prepare
himself for martyrdom.
And
she wasn't paying attention to her
toddler. She had a little son. And she
looked up and found that the son, her
toddler, had wandered over to Hubed and
sat on his lap. and in his hand was a
razor.
And so she became terrified that he was
going to hurt her son. And he saw the
look on her face and he said, "You think
I would hurt him? Of course I wouldn't
do this inshallah."
And so as they took him out to kill him,
the little boy Iban Hadith, he was a
young kid at the time, probably about
eight or nine years old.
And an older man
from
he took the young boy and said, "This
man, he killed your father. you need to
take his blood in his place. So he gave
him a spear
and he put his hand over the boy's hand
and he used the spear to continue to
stab Hub in the presence of all of these
people and they stabbed him to death
there and they crucified him and that is
when he said these words.
But do you want to know what is most
impressive about this story?
The boy,
he accepted Islam.
And the old man that took the boy's hand
and stabbed to death, he accepted Islam.
And the man that killed
the man that killed Zina,
he accepted Islam.
AND THE DAUGHTER THAT SPENT THAT TIME
WITH Hub in his in HER HOUSE, SHE
ACCEPTED ISLAM. As a matter of fact,
most of those tribes accepted Islam
because of what they saw from Kuben Z
during those few days that they were
held captive.
Much more impressive than any teaching
they could have done. They were used.
AND THIS IS WHY FUB SAID WHAT HE SAID.
IF ALLAH CHOOSES, he can use my body
TWISTED AND BROKEN, PLACE HIS BARAKA in
said body and use it for his purposes.
And so Allah did.
And he is the first of the companions to
make two raqai before martyrdom.
And he made two very brief ra. He said,
"I would have made prayer longer, but I
don't want you to think I'm afraid of
your execution. Let's get on with it.
Let's get this over with."
And so we see that our position in this
life is not to dictate TO ALLAH HOW AND
WHAT HE IS TO DO WITH US. Our position
is to prepare ourselves and hope that
Allah would use us in any way to further
his religion. Any one of us that is used
by Allah, this is an immense blessing
from Allah.
Be thankful lest Allah take it away from
[Arabic recitation]
Allah
Islam.
for
[Silence]
Allah.
Allah
[Silence]
becoming
Phil
[Silence]
Allah.
Allah
[Silence]
alhamdulillah.
Allah
sh
I I
high
[Silence]
Please double check your phones. If you
remembered to bring your phone into the
masid, double check it. Ensure that it
is silent so as not to interrupt our
time with Allah.
Ensure that your lines are as straight
and coherent as possible. Align your
shoulders and feet with the shoulders
and feet of your two neighbors.
Straightening the road is paramount and
part of our salah in Jama.
A straight road is largely what we will
be rewarded for in our prayer together.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
any
All
I
Allham
[Silence]
Allah
thou
Allah Oh,
[Arabic recitation]
Brothers and sisters, asalamu alaikum. I
got few announcements. Please bear with
me. First, I want to convey the
greetings from brother Roman.
Alhamdulillah. He's doing better, but
he is pass he's sending the greetings
and salams to every one of you. also
the the prayer times are changing
starting tomorrow inshallah. So please
take a note of this thing here. Fudger
prayer is at 5:45 a.m. Theama for fudger
will be at 5:45 a.m. So most of you can
join right. the assur is going to be
at 4:45 starting tomorrow. and Isha
will be at 7:30 starting tomorrow
inshallah. So today the schedule remains
the same. Everything is for tomorrow
morning and starting tomorrow morning
throughout the day inshallah. The
weekend school I just want to remind you
the registration is still open. This is
a good opportunity for you the
especially the children that are in the
public or private schools. They can
benefit from this program and at least
get the basics of Islam. So that is the
school is available to anybody between
the age of 5 and 7 to 17
and it is here on Sunday from 10:30 to
1:30 p.m. inshallah. U also please
donate generously on the way out. Also
that there is a a table outside for the
Rahma Academy. I just don't want
everybody to forget that alhamdulillah
we are we have expanded the program to
the fifth grade now. So we have up to
five grade from preK to 5. Anybody with
a child of that age they can benefit
from it and you can talk to brother
Ahmed Jabber to get some more details.
But believe me brothers and sisters this
is a tremendous opportunity that we have
that masjid is providing and please take
advantage of that. Please donate
generously on the way out.
I got to take the first one.
[Arabic recitation]
take your
So this is the other